there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time you know when you think
about your life
i think i i often tell people um that i
work with
if you can get because people people
have very high standards for
how they want their work life to be and
uh and i said look if you can get your
work life
to be where you enjoy half of it that is
a home
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead
that's reality everything comes with
pieces that you don't like
you could be a supreme court justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like
you can be a university professor and
it's still going to be
you have to go to committee meetings and
you have to do you know
there are every job comes with pieces
you don't like
and we need to say that's just how
that's part of it
and and not resent those pieces or try
not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false uh idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and so it's you have to figure out how
to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
and i find people don't dislike hard
work
what people dislike and is being
out of control like they can't control
their life they can't control their
environment
this happens to me when i get over
scheduled
i hate being over scheduled i want some
time
to be able to think and free myself we
all have the same amount of time in the
world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled
you have this event you had to agree to
do this and maybe last night you were
like
why did i agree to do this i have to go
on stage tomorrow
i wish i would really with my family and
you know or i hope maybe not
this case let's say that you like this
one but in general
that kind of thing happens and so you
have to guard your time
and and try to say a little bit flexible
so that's for me it's not a waste of
time
but i like to have some freedom of
movement
rather than having every minute of every
day
scheduled ever since i was five years
old that's when neil armstrong stepped
onto the surface of the moon
i've been um kind of passionate about
space rockets rocket engines space
travel
i became a science fiction reader
and i've always known that i wanted to
you know do something having to do with
space and i've spent a lot of time
thinking about it
for really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift
i think we all have passions and you
don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them
you have to be looking for them and when
you find your passion it's a fantastic
gift for you because
it gives you direction it gives you
purpose you can have a job or you can
have a career or you can have a calling
and the best thing is to have a calling
and if you find your passion you'll have
that and
all your work won't feel like work to
you we all get um
gifts uh we get certain things in our
life that are
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is who your early
role models are
you know you could they could it was
your grandfather it was in a big sense
my mom and dad but my grandfather too
and you know i had my mom had me when
she was
17 years old and she was still in high
school
in albuquerque new mexico and this is in
1964. i can assure you that
being a pregnant teenager in high school
was not cool
in albuquerque new mexico at that time
and
uh so it's in in
so it was a very it was difficult for
her my grandfather went to bat for her
when they tried to kick her out of
school and you know he they're
they're incredible i had so the gift i
had is i had this incredible family i
spent an unusual amount of time
with my grandparents and especially with
my grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south
texas and i would spend my summers there
from age 4 to 16.
and they when i was four they were
taking me for the summer to kind of give
my parents a break
you know sort of because they were so
young
and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure
and uh and anyway he he
he he created the illusion for me when i
was four years old that i was helping
him
on the ranch which of course could not
have been true
but i believed it and um and then as
by the time i was 16 of course i was
actually helping on the ranch i
you know i could i can fix prolapsed
cattle i can you know we did all of our
own veterinary work
some of the cattle even survived um
and we fixed windmills and laid you know
water pipelines and built fences and
barns and
fixed that fixed the bulldozer that you
guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that
lifestyle and about my grandfather is he
did everything
himself you know he didn't call a vet if
one of the animals was sick he figured
out
what to do himself and uh so what does
it mean no delegation being resourceful
i think is the you know that you can
always you can't if there's a problem
there's a solution and of course as you
as you mature and and get into the
business world and anything you do on a
team you very quickly realize that
it's not about just your own
resourcefulness it's about
team resourcefulness and how does that
work and when i
started amazon it was 25 years ago i
started
amazon in 1994 when i went to seek
investors the first question i had to
answer
is what is the internet none of my
investors had ever heard of the internet
and uh the
the the the the idea that i had in mind
was to build a bookstore i realized that
we could build a store
which would have every book ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
and we could do that online it would be
impossible in a physical store and that
was the founding idea of amazon
and but did i expect what would happen
today no you know we
started uh i've been at amazon when it
was one person
me when it was ten people when it was a
hundred people when it was a thousand
people
and today when it's you know more than
seven hundred thousand people and
approaching seventy
thousand people just here in india so
no i did not predict that and actually i
think if anybody had predicted that they
would have needed to be immediately
institutionalized in a mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen my dream when i started amazon
was that one day we might be able to
afford a forklift
so it's been a very uh fun journey for
me
and by the way i still tap dance into
work i'm having so much fun
we all have adversity in our lives i i
would
i would i doubt if you really you know
if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to um
there's no lack of adversity and the
uh and by the way that's good because
it's what teaches us how to get back up
you fall down you get back
up it always happens and you know you
get
certain um gifts in life and you want to
take advantage of those
but you i guess my advice on adversity
and uh success would be
to be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get in like you know you might
be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them
and thankful for them and but your
choices
you choose to work hard you choose to do
hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of
everything i've ever done has started
small amazon started with
a couple of people and
blue origin started with five people
and the budget at bloorigin was very
very small now the budget of blue
origins
approaches a billion dollars a year and
next year it'll be more than a billion
dollars
in amazon it literally was 10 people
today it's half a million people but
you it's hard to remember for you guys
but for me it's like yesterday i was
driving the
packages to the post office myself and
hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so
so for me i've seen small things get big
and it's part of this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small you know
amazon even though it is a large company
i wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one
we haven't had any existential crisis
knock on wood i
find i don't want to jinx anything
but we've had a lot of kind of
dramatic events i remember um
early on we only had 125
employees when barnes and noble who the
big
united states bookseller opened their
online website to compete against us
barnesandnoble.com we'd had about a two
year
window we opened in 95 they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were
about how we were about to be destroyed
by this much larger company we had 125
employees
and 60 million dollars a year in annual
sales
60 million with an m and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees
and about 3 billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were
very negative about amazon and the one
that's most minimal or
memorable was just amazon.toast
and um and so i called an all hands
meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and
because it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor
that literally everybody's parents were
calling
and saying you know are you okay it's
usually the moms
um calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay
so and i said look you know it it's okay
to be afraid
um but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never gonna
send us any money
be afraid of our customers and if we
just stay focused on them
in in in in instead of obsessing over
this big competitor that we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to
double down on the customer satisfying
them not just satisfying them delighting
them
i'm taking my amazon lottery winnings
and i'm converting them
into reusable rocket vehicles
so that we can lower the cost
of access to space because right now the
price of admission to do
interesting things in space is just too
high if i look at what
amazon was able to do 20 years ago
we didn't have to build a transportation
network it already existed that heavy
lifting was in
place we didn't have to build a payment
system that heavy lifting had already
been done it was the credit card system
we didn't have to build um put a
computer at every desk that had already
been done too mostly for playing games
by the way
and so on so all the pieces of heavy
lifting were already in place 20 years
ago
and that's why as with a million dollars
i could start this company
today you know and then there are even
better examples on the internet over the
last 20 years you know
facebook started in a dorm room i
guarantee you two kids cannot build a
giant space company in their dorm room
it's impossible but i want to create the
heavy lifting infrastructure kind of do
the hard part
so that a future the future generation
two kids in a dorm room will be able to
create a giant space company
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below
or if you want to watch an awesome clip
from a young jeff bezos check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there